as we said earlier tonight if your
school is an opening don't accept it
it's your child it's your money why
should you pay for a service you're not
getting reopen schools or give me my
school money back we said you should
take it to the course and fight for your
rights and your money and to explain how
that could work I'm joined now by a
member of president Trump's outside
legal team an executive director of the
American Center for Law and Justice
Jordan seculow Jordan thank you so much
for joining us tonight
you were the first family so personal I
thought of two to talk about this
because that I guess you've been in the
news and and we all know what's been
going on lately with respect to the
president's legal troubles and so on
should actually a really important part
of view of the ACL Jays work is
supporting these legal cases that really
drive forward a principle of freedom and
to me that that freedom of parents to
choose the best school for their child
especially at the school isn't offering
it all these reasons rate set out is
fundamental school choice has been an
issue that we have keyed in on and we've
argued all the way to the Supreme Court
for decades not just one decade but
decades and now we're starting to see
real results when it comes to school
choice those amendments that used to be
in place that prevented religious
schools from receiving voucher money
that was just struck down by the Supreme
Court that means all those amendments
that came about in the country when
there were a lot of Irish immigrants
Irish Catholic immigrants I mean think
about that it just doesn't seem right in
2020 that we had laws on the books and
that many states
40-plus states saying that we're not
going to give money to religious schools
even if we do have voucher programs
because we don't like Catholics that's
how that law starred in 1875 it was
finally basically struck down by the
Supreme Court this term in a case at the
Espinoza case out of Montana
that's great news but you point to the
second issue is it's great to have
school choice it's great to have
vouchers if their school if there is
school and what we're looking at now is
what happens for those underprivileged
kids the same ones we're working with
why we want vouchers and we believe
voters are the best
option you know tax credits they're
great they're wonderful but a lot of
these folks who are the most
underprivileged they're not even paying
taxes so these tax credits don't cover
enough sometimes they're $500 or even
$1,000 they don't cover the tuition what
we're looking at is voucher programs but
you've keyed on something important to
all of us with children is school coming
back I will tell you I get a different
email every few days from the school and
I'm not sure and it makes me nervous and
I'm in a situation fortunately where I
can figure something out most people are
not so let's let's look ahead and I just
want to give you a very specific
situation let's say there's a parent
watching tonight and they're fed up and
they say look I'm not getting the
answers I want from my school or my
school board I've had enough of it I
want to sue to take them to court to
give me the money like a voucher so I
can spend it somewhere else
could you help them with that legal
remedy yes so if it looks like in their
district already that there is not going
to be school and some have already
announced that or the school is not
going to be adequate for their child at
the american center for law and justice
one thing we do and this is separate
from our work as attorneys for the
present but the ACLJ we don't charge our
clients if you go to ACLJ org and you're
that person you just described Steve and
you put that information out you'll be
contacted by one of our senior attorneys
that doesn't cost you anything if we
decide that you've got a case that we
can go forward with it won't cost you
anything
we will fight the battle for you and I
think you've keyed in on a new battle
and I hope we can partner up you and me
and groups like us who can represent
these folks who would usually not have
the means to hire big law firms hey we
represent the president United States we
can take a local school district to
court or state to court don't worry
about that but people we can't do it
without clients so people have got to go
to ACLJ org they've got to tell us their
what their situation is and then we can
go to fight for them brilliant I knew I
knew you were the perfect person I'm so
excited just listening to you Jordan
thank you for explaining that so clearly
and I really want to encourage anyone
watching whether you're
parent you're a grandparent and you know
that the parents are frustrated about
this to listen to what Jordan just said
go to ACLJ de org and let's fight this
fight Jordan thank you so much for being
with us